what is going on there reject nation
greg here today we are going to watch the
trailer the red band one for the boys season
three i love the hell out of this show i heard
the boys diabolical's great my friend paul
from heavy spoilers recommends it immensely
it's covered some breakdowns for you guys
should go check it out yeah i haven't seen
any of the boys since we reacted
to the finale whenever the heck
that was regardless i'm very much excited for this
i'm glad my boy jensen ackles is joining this show
sam dude gotta do both you just gotta do both
sam and dean anyway guys if you could leave
a like i'd very much appreciate that i know
yeah john's out here because he had surgery
the other day so he's out of commission for
a few days but let's watch the stone together
but sure
did take some compound b
this is definitely magic
dragons too recognize that voice
oh interesting interesting
oh good for you man
there he was
cool
must be trying to level the playing field
milking oh
man that was definitely
homelander versus butcher sir
my boy's back with kripke can't wait man can't
wait gosh you know the boys is already fantastic
but if you're a supernatural fan much better
i'm only on season 9 of supernatural recovery
on patreon so uh still got like 25 more seasons
left to go there's a lot of that trailer let's
uh let's talk about it i mean first thoughts right
off the bat when i saw that promo image of butcher
with the the vision eyes the laser eyes i thought
that was just some like you know promo material or
something i didn't think it was gonna be an actual
thing where he would have superpowers so it seems
like he'd be taking compound v perhaps to help
level the playing field he's probably going to
the point after the death of becca that in order
for him to finally take down homelander he would
probably need some superpowers in order to do it
just going to kind of comb through this trailer
and see what i can pick up i'm loving all these
glimpses that we've been getting of homelanders
because this performance of him and at least
in this brief images that we got in after the
events of last season he just seems incredibly
emasculated it's the way i probably surmise the
performance of anthony stars of lake who i hear
can really hold down his liquor incredibly well
you get this interesting shot of huey early
on which if i'm not mistaken he joins newman's
campaign at the end of season two still in like
a suit and ties i don't know this looks like it
could be him maybe early on learning the truth
about newman the trailer was going by so fast
so i'm not even sure if we saw her i'm assuming
she'd probably be like one of the the main baddies
for this particular season we got to unpack that
as well there you'll see this is where you guys
come and help me out three beautiful sobs come
in is this uh mother's milk looking for someone
specific i see a sign here that says superhero or
slayer kind of looks like jensen ackles up there
at the top but i can't really tell there is an
image here of soldier boy right in front of him
maybe he's tracking down soldier but what i've
read up on about soldier boy he's essentially
a play on like captain america part of a team
called payback which eric kripke describes as
payback was the seven before the seven they were
like the world's first superhero team during world
war ii and we're gonna be exploring the history
of that team looks like we'll be dealing a lot
with flashbacks but the same time towards the
end of this trailer it seems like perhaps that
they are doing something that's like a major riff
on captain america in the sense of like he's from
the past but now he's brought back to the present
perhaps resurrected or he was frozen or something
like that like he was gone for for decades and now
he's back you're gonna be seeing other characters
from that team called payback like in the trailer
you saw this character named crimson countess
who has heat vision and can manipulate fire what
i was reading up on is that soldier boy he was
part of the payback team he was technically team
leader but was disrespected and overpowered by
stormfront that's right stormfront was on his tame
so in comparison he was a little bit weak to her
and he always wanted a spot in the seven and it's
freaking jensen axles man okay i'm so excited to
know this moment here with atran looks like it's
a spoof on that college jedi except he's got
turbo rush instead of pepsi this moment here i was
reading up on that there's gonna be some type of
reality show called i think it's called an
american hero it's gonna be a competition
show where there's like 10 supes who are fighting
for one of the spots of the seven and that this
guy right here is a character named supersonic
who is starlight's ex-boyfriend reportedly which
i'm sure will create some wonderful tension
looks like ashley and the director of what's
oh you do get this one moment here i can't tell
if that's newman who's exploding this person
is that newman looks like newman i do think that
this shot right here where you go into the deep's
eyes is the moment where we will finally see
brought to live action the thing that everyone's
been talking about since the season was announced
herogasm so in herogasm homelander announces that
like the the superheroes of earth are banning
together to fight an alien invasion in space but
when they end up doing is actually they fly
to like a remote island for a wild ass orgy
and in reality that's where john's at right now
he didn't need surgery he just wanted to party
never invites me to the damn orgies and then
the boys got to like infiltrate that mission
i don't know how i've seen some images of it
and i don't know how you even for amazon like
that's pretty risque but eric kripke has a lot of
confidence in the script that they have that they
can really pull this one off and i actually
seen the deep there who uh this is probably
a very triggering moment for him and he's probably
gonna really spiral downhill into this this liquid
abyss i mean they would have this moment here
with the deep where he's like dude with a girl
oh god that is uh that is hilarious but then of
course at the center of all butcher homelander
going toe-to-toe with each other either way
this trailer is awesome i love the hell out
of this trailer i thought it was really violent
gazillion details that i'm sure flew way over
my head i can't wait for the show man guys what
did you think about it leave your thoughts down
below are you excited for the boys season three
subscribe click the notification bell leave a like
and uh last month let's do it anis oliver i gotta
shout you out in this video because you're the one
who gave me this shirt now nissa i know that when
it's just me on camera you're very disappointed
you're all about that john you're wishing you're
part of that herogasm party with him right now
but with me you'll get sincerity you would not
participate in the herogasm if i was i just know
i could have reality i was saying you messed me in
a while say hello i don't know what your deal is
it's kind of bothering me because i thought i
said i would do sincerity but it's not happening
i am planning on trying to go to texas there
are people who i want to collab with out there
there's a studio of a certain youtuber who i'm
like i want to be on your channel and i would
like to go out there and he said i could stay at
his place and i found out it's in the same area
where you live when john and i go out there we do
got to pay you a visit we got to hang out buy you
a beer and it's going to be a great time plenty of
alcohol required you're one of the best people in
the world i've ever known i mean that sincerely
i'll never forget everything you've done for us
over the years looks like it's finally happening
i'll finally meet in person i know you'll only
respond to that meetup if john messages you
directly fine whatever all right bye anissa